earth is home to around 1 billion trees
that belong to over 60 thousand
species and they live on every continent
but
antarctica and while they may seem
extremely vulnerable to environmental
changes
seeing as they can't get up and leave
when the climate no longer suits them
trees have actually been around for
close to 400 million years
they've survived all four extinction
events that they've been around for
and their ability to break down rocks
create soil
and siphon carbon dioxide from the air
and replace it with oxygen
is what made our planet habitable for
humans
but however grateful foresters poets and
lumberjacks
might be for their presence trees have
always been a bit difficult to
understand
when it comes to finding similarities
between trees and animals
there's not a lot to work with trees are
immobile
don't have blood or lymph or nervous
systems
and only need sunlight and water to
produce their own supply of food
they can live for thousands of years
growing slowly taller and wider
one great base in bristlecone pine is
over 5 000 years old
and even in a forest they seem like
solitary individuals
competing for access to sunlight but
otherwise having no interactions with
their neighbors
but as it turns out there's more to
trees than meets the eye
it was only a matter of looking deeper
down to the roots instead of up to the
canopy
while we might only see and hear the
birds and squirrels filling forests with
noise
there's a vast network of communication
happening right
under our feet trees sharing resources
passing on warnings and passing down
information over the generations
a network of trees talking it allows the
forest to behave as if it's a single
organism
and makes scientists rethink the
evolution of tree
life is it based on competition
or cooperation and by understanding this
network
we might be able to unlock secrets that
will help in our fight against
deforestation and climate change as a
whole
on our planet mutualism is a fundamental
part of many organisms biology
the clownfish that gets protection from
an anemone the anemone that gets
nutrients from the fish
the cleaner ras who eats parasites from
reef fish
the reef fish staying healthy the bees
that gather nectar from flowers while
the pollen stuck to their bodies
pollinates it
but perhaps the most widespread and
ecologically significant symbiosis is
one we can't see
a partnership between soil fungi and
land plants
in 1885 german botanist albert bernard
frank
first proposed the idea that plant roots
and the fungi around them
were working together and like with many
bold scientific assertions he was
basically laughed out of the room
but in the last century nearly all of
frank's major hypotheses have been
unequivocally demonstrated
we now know that plant and fungal
associations
known as mycorrhizal associations are
present in almost
all ecosystems from deserts to tropical
forests
and that about 90 percent of terrestrial
plants
are connected to some form of
mycorrhizal fungi network
mycorrhizae are a fungus which grows in
association with the roots of a plant in
a symbiotic relationship
the most common fungal networks are made
of arbuscular mycorrhiza
which are named for the latin arbiscule
meaning little tree
the threads of this fungi penetrate the
root cells of their host
and form tiny structures inside of them
this is how they interact with the trees
and share resources with them
the other major class of fungi are
ectomycorrhizal fungi
these fungi form a sheath around the
roots of their hosts
and grow between the plant cells to
exchange nutrients
they have a symbiotic relationship with
fewer plants than the arbuscular
mycorrhizae
but their hosts tend to be the most
economically important trees
as they are often the most widespread
trees that we use for timber
while the two classes of fungal networks
belong to very different species
their relationship with the host plants
are pretty similar
the fungi pick up water and nutrients
from the soil
including phosphorus and nitrogen which
are both
important for plant growth and transfer
them to their plant hosts
in return the plants transfer their
fungal friends between
four and twenty percent of their
photosynthate
the sugars they produce by
photosynthesizing this relationship is
the backbone of all
our forests on earth and without it life
on land as we know it may have never
emerged
but in recent decades scientists have
realized it's not just the individual
tree and the fungi that have a
relationship
sharing resources back and forth but
that the trees themselves are connected
by this intricate
vast network
the first inkling that trees might
actually work together
came in a study in the early 1980s
scientists planted pines side by side in
a box
in the lab then inoculated their roots
with the mycorrhizal fungi to establish
an
underground fungal network then they
tagged the photosynthetic sugars
produced by the donor pine with
radioactive carbon
they did this by sealing one plant in a
box with radioactive carbon dioxide
they then allowed the pine to absorb it
and convert it into radioactive sugars
through photosynthesis
then they placed photographic film over
the side of the root box
hoping to see where the radioactive
particles traveled from one plant to the
other
or if they traveled at all when they
developed the film
they saw the path that the charged
particles had taken
and the path was through the mycorrhizal
fungal network
traveling from one tree to the other the
idea that trees may
share resources presented scientists
with an evolutionary paradox
trees have always been known to evolve
by competing
not cooperating trees grow tall to reach
the most sunlight
their roots branch far and wide to suck
up the most
water those that get shaded or reach
less water
often don't survive if trees of the same
species
or even of different species shared
resources
scientists would be forced back to the
drawing board with their understanding
of how
trees have evolved and this idea is what
got researcher suzanne simmered excited
in one of her early experiments she
looked at nutrient exchange between
douglas fir trees and paper birch trees
two different species that grow together
in forests and sometimes compete for
space and light
she planted fur birch and cedar
seedlings in a trio
she labeled the paper birch with the
radioactive isotope carbon 14
and labeled the douglas fir with a
stable isotope carbon 13.
that way she could tell not only if
carbon was moving from birch to fur
but could tell if it was moving from fur
to birch the cedar plants acted as a
control
cedar can't form mycorrhizal networks
with the fur or birch
for the simple reason that it forms
arbuscular mycorrhizae
not ectomycorrhizal like the other two
if
cedar roots acquire any of the labeled
sugars created by fur
or birch it would mean that they had
leaked through the soil
not through the fungal network she then
covered the fur with a shade
tent reducing the amount they were able
to photosynthesize
if the two trees were linked in a
microrizal network
cooperating with one another then the
surplus of photosynthetic sugars from
the birch
should flow into the roots of the fur
and what she found was that the birch
and fir trees
indeed share resources in fact the more
shade the fur was covered by
the more carbon 14 it received from the
birch
and the cedar did not receive either of
the isotopes
further experiments showed that these
two species are also
able to share nitrogen and share
resources in both directions depending
on the season and conditions
the two species exist in an alternate
feedback system
helping each other when the other needs
it allowing them both to remain healthy
but it's not only a matter of sharing
resources
other experiments have looked at the
chemicals trees produce to signal that
they're being damaged by voracious
insects
pathogens or human activity one
experiment looked at tomato plants
all linked up through an arbuscular
mycorrhizal network
when the researchers infested some of
the plants with leaf-chewing
caterpillars
healthy neighbors had activated four
defense-related genes within 6
hours in other words they knew trouble
was coming and they were preparing for
it
as it turns out this preparation helped
them the plants that had time to produce
defensive enzymes against the pests
fared better
and the caterpillars munching on those
second plants didn't grow as large
and there's also evidence that trees of
the same species have some form of kin
recognition
through their fungal networks they can
identify which trees are most closely
related to them
and direct more resources towards those
trees
these experiments show us that trees
aren't solitary individuals
but live in a cooperative harmony with
one another
but if they're so cooperative does this
challenge the prevailing theory that
cooperation is less important than
competition in evolution
it might seem like the law of natural
selection would cause trees to only
compete for resources
but their cooperation isn't purely
selfless
if neighboring trees die gaps open up in
the protective forest canopy
with more sunlight the remaining trees
can carry out more photosynthesis
yes but they're also more vulnerable
more hot sunshine reaches the delicate
forest floor
heating up and drying out the cool damp
evenly regulated microclimate that
forest trees need
winds are able to penetrate the forest
more easily and without neighboring tree
crowns to stabilize against it
the chance of being uprooted increases
reasons like this is why they've evolved
to help their neighbors
trees live longer and reproduce more
often in a healthy
stable forest and if we can understand
this network
we can minimize some of the worst
impacts that humans have
on the planet
in her research on tree connection and
communication suzanne simmered and her
team found that the biggest
oldest trees what are called the mother
trees
are the hubs of these below ground
fungal networks
they are the most connected nodes in the
network of the forest
mother trees share their excess carbon
and nitrogen through the mycorrhizal
network with the understory seedlings
which can increase seedling survival in
a single forest
a mother tree can be connected to
hundreds of other trees
but the problem is this we're great at
clear cutting
and great at clear-cutting mother trees
we always
either log the entire forest or go for
the biggest oldest trees because they're
the most valuable
but if too many of these mother trees
are logged
too many of the nodes removed the forest
as a whole
will start to decline disease can start
to spread
insects start campaigns of destruction
but with this research
hopefully a shift can start to happen
understanding that trees in a forest are
connected underground to their kin and
to their neighbors
could change the way trees are logged
when forests are harvested
the retention of mother trees can
provide resilience
smaller hope trees can be removed
without causing the network to collapse
leaving enough hub trees and enough of
the mother trees within the network
allows for the flow of communication and
the trading of resources to continue
retaining mother trees can also help the
forest regenerate
seeds from the mother tree will sprout
nearby and are able to
quickly tap into the mycorrhizal network
and receive resources from their
community that boost their chances of
survival
additionally experiments have shown that
the retention of old trees
and their extensive networks can reduce
loss of carbon from the ecosystem
both above and below ground researchers
are now investigating how the
connections between mother trees
seedlings and other plants enhance
resilience of the forest community
maintaining the network of connections
between trees in a forest
should help them resist the stress of
climate change and recover more rapidly
when climate-related disturbances do
occur
connected forests are better able to
cope with climate change and be more
productive healthy and diverse
our need for trees is not going away
anytime soon
so learning how to best utilize this
resource for its health and
ours will be imperative in years to come
and now that scientists are starting to
have a better understanding of the
mycorrhizal network
they're looking for ways to utilize it
not just in the forests
but in our agricultural fields the
majority of staple food crops are known
to form relationships with mycorrhizal
fungi
if the soil is in good enough condition
for the fungi to flourish
these fungi could provide crops with
nitrogen and phosphorus
which means the farmers wouldn't be so
reliant on fertilizer
it could be a natural scalable and
elegant solution to chip away at the
damage
agriculture causes on the planet while
absolutely necessary for humanity
agriculture is one of the most damaging
things we do to the planet
a lot needs to change but on a personal
scale it's sometimes hard to feel like
we can make a difference
while we may not be able to change land
use practices in brazil
or influence lobbyists in the u.s the
least we can do is try to be responsible
in our own lives
and until recently i wasn't really doing
that
after moving into my own apartment last
year i became
so bad about wasting food i didn't know
how to grocery shop for one person
and would inevitably overbuy and even if
my planning was okay
sometimes you just need a tablespoon of
sour cream for a recipe
not an entire container that will sit
there and go moldy
and this is why i decided to give hello
fresh a try
i love to cook but was so tired of the
food waste i was creating
hellofresh gives you pre-portioned
ingredients to make
quick delicious meals like these little
packets of sour cream
so not only are you not wasting entire
tubs of sour cream
you don't have to fuss with measuring
things out i feel like it's a small
thing i can do to reduce my
environmental impact
and something i can do to care for
myself too
plus you can easily change your delivery
days or food preferences
and skip a week whenever you need and on
top of this
the packaging hellofresh uses to ship
your food
is also almost entirely made from
recyclable
and or already recycled material upping
your sustainability points
so if you're ready to free up your time
eat healthy meals
and help the planet go to hellofresh.com
and use code
realscience12 to get 12 free meals
including free shipping that's almost
two weeks of free dinners
and if you're looking for something else
to watch right now you can watch our
previous video about mad cow disease
or watch real engineering's latest video
the truth about biofuels
a great video debunking many common
beliefs about the biofuel industry
you